>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Catherine Kerst: Well, it's
a pleasure for me to be here.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Thank you.
>> Catherine Kerst: Speaking
with you, and I look forward
to learning more about Kuchipudi
and about your background.
First, maybe you could
tell us a little bit
about this classical
dance form from India.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Sure.
Kuchipudi is one of eight
classical styles of India,
and it comes from a southern,
southeastern state
called Andhra Pradesh.
And, Kuchipudi gets its name from
a village by the name Kuchipudi
which is located in Andhra.
And, Kuchipudi also another
characteristic feature
about Kuchipudi is that it was
started by an all-male group
of dancers, or rather one man
by the name of Siddhendra Yogi
who took a young group, a
group of young Brahman boys
and started teaching them the
Kuchipudi as we know it today
which is, which is
about 500 years old.
Kuchipudi otherwise can be
traced back all the way to well
over 2000 years ago where,
and we can say this only
because we have evidence from temple
sculptures and also other evidence
of classical, thriving classical
Indian dance and music culture
in India from mural
paintings in caves as well as,
as well as beautiful
sculptures of dancers in temples.
So, even though we know
that Kuchipudi originated somewhere
before around 2000 years ago.
>> Catherine Kerst: That's amazing.
>> Anuradha Nehru: The
Kuchipudi that we say
that we practice today comes
from the village of Kuchipudi
which was founded by Siddhendra Yogi
in this village called Kuchipudi.
I can go on, but I don't.
>> Catherine Kerst:
I'm curious to know,
you said there are eight
different classical forms.
What is distinctive about the
Kuchipudi as opposed to these other?
>> Anuradha Nehru: You know,
all eight Indian classical
dance styles are in,
draw their inspiration from the
same text called the Natya Shastra,
and the Natya Shastra was,
is very wide in its scope.
It's, and it covers chapters,
there are chapters
dedicated to music and dance.
It's a 36 chapter book which covers
all aspects of performance art.
And, so all eight Indian classical
styles draw their inspiration
from this text, however each
of these styles developed
and interpreted dance based on their
own regional cultural influences.
And, just as each of
these, each of the states
in India are pretty
different culturally,
the dance forms reflect that, and so
Kuchipudi as we practice it today,
as I said before, came from what
Siddhendra Yogi developed 500
years ago.
And, because it was an all-male
dance form up until 75 years ago,
it tends to be a more vigorous
dance form relative to, say,
Bharatanatyam, Odissi which are
its neighboring dance forms.
The other interesting characteristic
trait of Kuchipudi is that it is,
it's both, it's got three, I'm
getting very technical here.
It sits between Tamil
Nadu and Odisha in India,
and it's a perfect
amalgamation of those two styles.
For example, Odissi is
a very fluid dance form.
It's, it literally feels like it,
the dance flows from one's culture
as opposed to another in movement.
And, contrasting that,
Bharatanatyam which is
from Tamil Nadu is a very rigid,
geometrical dance form
where there are.
It's highly classical, but
they draw geometric shapes
in space through dance.
And, Kuchipudi sits somewhere
between these two where it's fluid,
at the same time it's
quite structured as well.
That's the best way
I can describe that.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's wonderful.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Movement.
>> Catherine Kerst: [inaudible].
>> Anuradha Nehru: And, of course,
the other characteristic feature is
a lot of the poetry and the lyrics
that we use for Kuchipudi
dance comes
from the poets written
in the language Telugu.
So, a lot of the dances
are choreographed
to poetry written by
Telugu or Sanskrit.
Whereas, the other forms
use other languages
that are more common
in their regions.
>> Catherine Kerst: It's also a
story telling format, in a sense.
Is it?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes.
>> Catherine Kerst: Would you
call it a dance drama format?
>> Anuradha Nehru: And, the other
characteristic for, yes, very,
very important feature of Kuchipudi
is Kuchipudi's history, rather,
is that it is a dance drama form.
It was a dance drama
form 500 years ago,
and only in the past 70 years
or so, because of gurus.
My guru, Guru Vempati
Chinna Satyam and his guru,
Guru Lakshminarayana Sastry that
who moved out of the village
of Kuchipudi and into the larger
metropolis city of Chennai
which used to be called Madras.
And, they incorporated not
only women into the style,
but they started developing
the solo format for Kuchipudi.
So, today, what we perform is
largely the solo dance form.
Although, the dance drama
form is still very vibrant
in India as well as here.
>> Catherine Kerst: So,
in the current expression,
is story telling an
important part, still?
>> Anuradha Nehru:
Extremely, yes, extremely.
Storytelling continues to be an
important part of Indian dance.
I think dance in general is a
medium of expression, and it,
we could tell stories or express
or communicate to our audiences
through stories, but the dance
form itself as enough in it.
There is enough depth and
complexity in the dance
to communicate even secular
themes or abstract themes
through the form which is, yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: Fascinating.
So, your native language
is Telugu which is.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes.
It is.
>> Catherine Kerst: The
context in which the form.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes, yes.
Since I was born and brought up in
Hyderabad which, and I am a Telugu.
So, Kuchipudi seemed to be
the most natural dance style
for me to learn growing up.
>> Catherine Kerst: Did you,
did you study from an early age?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes, I
started early at the age of eight
in Hyderabad and continued
throughout,
throughout my schooling
as well as college.
And, really never really gave it up.
I never really thought I would make
dance my career, but always danced
because I loved to dance.
And, having moved to America
right after I got married,
I was extremely skeptical about
being able to continue to dance,
leave alone teach to the next
generation of dancers this art form.
And, but today, 25 years later,
I'm so, so deeply happy to find
that not only could,
not only Kuchipudi seems
to be flourishing here in the
United States, but there is a sense
of connectedness that the
dance students here feel
to their heritage, through
their learning of this dance.
And, just to briefly explain the
most recent dance that we presented
in celebration of our 25 years.
We did a new work called "Why We
Dance", and the new work revolved
around the feelings and the
thoughts of the Kalanidhi dancers.
And, four basic themes emerged
when I asked them the questions
to why they dance, and one
of them was their connection
to their heritage.
And, the second was the sense
of freedom and liberation
from their mundane, routine lives.
The third was storytelling which
they felt, for that period of time,
for them time is suspended and
they take their audience with them
into the stories they
tell through dance.
And, the fourth was the sense
of community that they feel
and the most open and honest
relationships that they have is
with their fellow dancers
and how special that is.
So, I just felt those thoughts
were so well articulated
by the Kalanidhi dancers that
we decided to develop work
around those four concepts.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, you
choreographed [inaudible].
>> Anuradha Nehru: So, I
choreographed around those concepts.
>> Catherine Kerst: Wonderful.
>> Anuradha Nehru: With completely
traditional, classical music
which was commissioned
for this project.
I went to India to get the music
recorded, and we choreographed
and presented it last week.
And, all of the dancers, we
used their quotes as well
as then showed the dance
expressing those sentiments.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, where
the quotes were said aloud,
or were they?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Were said aloud.
>> Catherine Kerst: Oh, wonderful.
>> Anuradha Nehru: We used
the voices of the dancers.
>> Catherine Kerst: Oh.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
So, it, we've come a long way, I
feel, with it's a dream come true
to be able to bring Kuchipudi to the
United States for me, and I truly.
And, one of our, of my, certainly
my vision and Kalanidhi's vision is
to try and bring Indian dance,
to put Indian dance alongside the
mainstream dance in this country.
I do believe it belongs there.
>> Catherine Kerst: I think it does.
I mean it is a, is an
incredible classical form.
Beautiful, and very
moving even, as you say,
if a person is not well
versed in Hindu mythology
and the spiritual aspects and
the stories, the narratives
that out of which it comes.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah,
I think there's several layers
of, and of Indian dance.
A lot of depth and complexity to it,
and partly because of, I believe,
the 2000 years of evolution
and refinement
that this art form has had.
But, I also feel it provides us
as Indian dancers an opportunity
to communicate some of the values
that are reflected in the stories
that we tell through Indian dance
because Indian dance is not
only communicating the stories,
but it's also communicating
the values of life which is,
which is one of the
purposes of Indian dance.
And, in our, again,
most recent production,
we tried to bring the meaning
of what it is that we're trying
to portray through our dance
through the use of the surtitles
where all the lyrics
were translated.
And so, our audience had an
opportunity to simultaneously,
to lifetime understand what
it is that we are telling,
whether it be a story or whether
it be, you know, slokas or poetry
from our, from you know, written
way back from 2000 years ago.
We took, we took poems
from the Natya Shastra,
and we presented that.
And, we had translation
at the same time.
And so, I do feel all of this
helps bring Indian dance closer
to our audiences here in America.
>> Catherine Kerst: Sure.
Can you give an example of the
values that, and example of...
>> Anuradha Nehru: You know, well.
>> Catherine Kerst: ...
or a sloka that would
have something.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Sure.
Yeah. For example, when
we were trying to present
to our audience the heritage
aspect of our "Why We Dance" work.
So, some of the values
that we try and teach
through Indian dance is respect.
Respect not only and
humility, respect and humility.
And, just in terms of how we
begin each class with namaskar
which where we remember to offer our
prayers or salutations to the gods
and then to our teachers.
And, it reflects in how we, where
we place our hands whether it's,
when it's above our
head, it's to the gods.
When it's at our forehead,
it's to our teachers
because they signify knowledge
or the passing of knowledge.
And then, when we place our
hands in front of our chest,
it is offering our prayers
or salutations to all of you
in the audience, for example.
And then, we respect
for Mother Earth.
It's extremely important that
we acknowledge Mother Earth
for all her beauty and
for what she offers us.
And then, we always start
with doing a namaskar
to Mother Earth before
we beat upon her.
And, these are just very,
they're simple gestures,
but they have a lot of
significance to them.
And, so, it's teaching, in
this context, yes, Mother Earth
and teachers and our gods,
but it translates itself to,
in our daily lives, we have to,
we have to practice humility.
We have to practice respect, and
those are just some examples.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's wonderful.
That's very helpful.
I'm curious to know how different
your relationship with Guru Vempati
as a guru as you were growing up
is, was, what it was like to be
in that classroom and how it differs
from your relationship
with your students.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes,
significantly different.
Growing up in India, you know,
teachers, we kept, you know,
teachers were placed on a
pedestal and highly respected.
And, of course, my guru
was so knowledgeable,
and but the big difference
is I feel growing up in India
and learning dance from him was
amazing, was an amazing experience
to learn whatever he
had to impart to me.
But, we were never
encouraged to ask questions.
We just had to be there and absorb
everything that he had to give us,
and coming to this
country and teaching here,
children here are not used to
just taking what is given to them.
So, right from the very beginning,
they would ask questions.
And, in the early years, it took
a while for me, it was, it was,
in retrospect the best thing
that could have happened
because I learned so
much more through having
to answer those questions.
I had to go back and understand
the art form at a much deeper level
in order to teach them and in
order to answer their questions.
So, I think that was
a big difference
where asking questions seemed to be
the most natural thing for students
in this country, and
teaching them required that.
And, I didn't, I didn't demand the
same kind of relationship that I had
with my guru from my students in
terms of them having to, you know,
do the namaskar to me every time.
I believed that if they felt
the respect in their hearts,
then it would show
itself in their actions.
And, it took time, but,
over time, then they began
to realize the value
of their learning.
It came from their heart rather
than being told to do something,
which is, again, a big difference
in my teaching experience
with my students.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, how old
are the youngest who come to you?
>> Anuradha Nehru: I -- six years.
>> Catherine Kerst: Six.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Six
all the way to adult,
but I like to start teaching
students from a young age
because that's the
best time to start.
>> Catherine Kerst: And, are they
mostly born in the United States?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Oh, yes.
Almost all of them.
So, they're, yeah, which is why
I feel, it, which is why I was
so surprised when I saw how
connected they felt to this dance
because they're not,
they haven't grown
up in the same culture
that I grew up in.
But, yet, there is something
in the art form itself
that makes them connected to very
deeply, and they have a passion
for it which is amazing
for me to watch.
>> Catherine Kerst: It, you
can see it in the performance.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Which is why
I'm so committed to making sure
that Kalanidhi continues beyond
me and for trying our level best
to put Kuchipudi up there
alongside other art forms
because it truly belongs
in this country today.
I think. And, the next generation
of dancers are passionate enough
about Kuchipudi that I hope
they'll be able to take it forward.
Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
So, in your teaching, do you,
do you have a range of the ages?
Do the young ones take a class
with the older students, or?
>> Anuradha Nehru: No.
I do, I do separate them.
They, I teach in very small groups
because I feel dancers
best start in small groups.
Kuchipudi is best started in
small groups, but I do offer a,
what I call a common class or
a combined class once a week
to which students of all levels
are encouraged to attend.
And, the objective of that
common class is for interaction
between the juniors and the seniors,
for the juniors to be inspired
by the senior, for them to see
where they're working towards,
what is the next level and what is
the best level for them to get to.
As well as the combined class
allows, allows for, you know,
other things like stamina building
because it's a solid
two hour session
where all the fundamentals
are reviewed.
So, it, and I, my attempt was
also to try and simulate the kind
of classes I used to
have back in India
where we had all ages come
together at the same time.
>> Catherine Kerst: Oh, really?
>> Anuradha Nehru: And,
everybody started together,
and as the class became more and
more complex, the younger ones sat
down and watched the older dancers.
And, that was on an everyday basis.
Here, it's impossible to do that.
Students have busy lives.
Students have busy routines.
They have many other
activities, and so they often come
for this one hour a week which
is so secluded, in a sense.
They just learn their few
steps, and they have no idea
of what else there
is to Indian dance.
So, the combined class
offers them a glimpse.
>> Catherine Kerst: And
then, some of the students go
on to have a final performance.
Do they graduate?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
We have what's called rangapravesam.
A rangapravesam is the literal
meaning of rangapravesam is entry
to stage, entry onto stage.
And, it's a debut performance,
a debut solo performance,
and that usually requires years
of practice because they have
to present a 90 to 100 minute
presentation of dance all alone
which requires a lot of training.
And, typically, that takes 10
to 12 years of training before,
and that's considered the basic
requirement before you can go
on to becoming a professional
dancer if you so choose to.
>> Catherine Kerst: Do many of your
students go on to pursue dance,
or how does it fit into their lives?
>> Anuradha Nehru:
Yeah, so that, that was,
again, a big surprise for me.
I think a lot of students
come up to that stage,
they do their solo performance,
and then they move on.
But, to me, the surprising
thing about Kalanidhi is a lot
of my Kalanidhi dancers have
done their rangapravesam,
but they've wanted to
continue because they,
some of them have gone
away and come back.
And so, I do feel we've developed
this community of dancers
where there's something that's
pulling them back to dance,
and I've got a large number of
my company dancers have come back
after their solo rangapravesam
to join the company
and to be with the company.
And, unfortunately, in the
arts, I've been unable to,
unable to hire them
on a full-time basis
because we just can't afford to.
But, I do know if we can get to
that point, I would have a group
of dancers who would
dedicate their lives to this.
But, we are Kalanidhi
are working towards that.
It is our goal to try and develop a
core group at a core dance company
which we can support professionally.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's admirable.
Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: So,
how long has Kalanidhi.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Kalanidhi.
>> Catherine Kerst: Kalanidhi
gone, been in existence?
>> Anuradha Nehru: 25 years.
>> Catherine Kerst: 25 years,
yeah, that's what you said.
>> Anuradha Nehru: We just
had our 25th year celebration.
Yeah, '91 is when I
started Kuchipudi Kalanidhi.
>> Catherine Kerst: And, can you
tell us, what does the word mean?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Kalanidhi.
"Kala" is art, and
"nidhi" is treasure.
So, it's a treasure of art,
treasure chest of art is the name.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
Have you traveled with
the group to India?
>> Anuradha Nehru:
Yes, we did, in 2007.
There's a festival in India, New
Delhi, called Ananya festival
which is presented every October
in front of the Purana Qila,
the Red Fort, one of the most
prestigious dance festivals
where only Indian dance
groups are, dance companies
from India are presented.
So, we felt extremely privileged
and humbled when they invited us
to present Kalanidhi dancers
there and Kalanidhi work there.
So, we did that in 2007, and
we made a tour out of it.
We traveled the Kalakshetra
and presented there.
Kalakshetra is the premiere
dance institute in India.
And, I went to my hometown,
Hyderabad, and presented there.
So, that was also thrilling for me.
>> Catherine Kerst: And,
to the students, too.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And,
for the students, too.
>> Catherine Kerst: Very, very.
>> Anuradha Nehru: It was an
amazing experience for all of them,
and one of the limiting factors
for Kalanidhi today to tour is
that we don't have a, we're not
able to support dancers full-time.
And, I do believe once we get
to that stage, we can tour.
Touring, we're unable to tour today
because they all have
other commitments.
They're either in college
or they're working.
And, being able to support them
professionally would mean we can not
only tour overseas, but we
can tour within the country.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Which
we would love to do.
>> Catherine Kerst: And, I'm
sure there are many communities
who would welcome that.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: Throughout
the U.S. they would be fascinated.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah because
it takes a lot of time and effort
to put a work together and to
present it, and then it's a bit
of a shame that we're
unable to tour with it.
>> Catherine Kerst: You've
also done some innovative work
with musical forms
that are very different
from Indian classical forms.
Could you talk a little
bit about that?
[BEGIN]
>> Anuradha Nehru: Sure.
Yeah. It, you know, even, it was
in 2012 that we were approached
by the Artistic Director
of Opera Lafayette,
Ryan Brown, to collaborate with him.
And, even before then,
Kalanidhi, in Kalanidhi,
we were always experimenting
the different genres of music
and we would choreograph to fill
up class, and we would choreograph
to different forms of music.
So, there was this interest and --
to experiment with the
different kinds of music.
And, we put up some of our videos on
the web, and Ryan Brown saw a couple
of our videos on the web and liked
what he saw and contacted us.
And, that's how this opportunity
came to us, and as a result
of meeting with Ryan Brown, we
ended up collaborating with him
in two operas which was a
fabulous experience for us.
We worked on a 19th century opera
called Lalla Roukh and presented
with his opera company in 2013.
And then, on a second
opera work in 2014
which was based on Rameau's work.
And, both of them were
fabulous experiences.
The second work, not
only was a collaboration
with the opera company, but he
invited two other dance companies,
a modern dance company as well
as a baroque dance company
and had the three dance
companies work with each other.
So, it was a fabulous
collaborative effort where --
>> Catherine Kerst:
So, dancing to Rameau?
>> Anuradha Nehru:
Dancing to Rameau.
>> Catherine Kerst: Amazing.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And
interacting and choreographing
with a modern dance company
choreographer as well
as a baroque dance
company choreographer.
So, it was a really
exciting collaboration,
and I do believe we
all pulled it off.
It came out -- we enjoyed it.
We thoroughly, thoroughly
learned a lot from each other
and enjoyed the whole
process of working together,
working with each other, and I
really, really hope that this opens
up avenues, not just for Kalanidhi
but for Indian dance in this country
to work with not only
other musical forms
but with other dance forms as well.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's so exciting, and.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Truly exciting.
>> Catherine Kerst: And, it
would be so easy to say, well,
I don't think it would
work, and yet, it did.
>> Anuradha Nehru: It did.
Yes.
>> Catherine Kerst: In amazing ways.
>> Anuradha Nehru: It did.
Because, yeah, ultimately,
I do believe music
and dance are universal
languages, and it is.
And, what better way to
bridge the cultural gap?
>> Catherine Kerst: Exactly, yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Other than,
yeah, music and dance, I think.
It provides us a perfect opportunity
to, not only create artistic work
but to understand each other's
culture in this process.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, when
the group traveled to India,
was it mostly traditional classical
Indian music that you danced to?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes, yes.
We took a work called "Rasa" which
was an exploration of the nine moods
as described in the Natya Shastra,
but these nine moods are
universal to mankind.
And so, we, the experimentation
in that work was to try
and depict these nine emotions
with abstract Indian dance
as opposed to storytelling.
The traditional way to depict
the nine moods is to select, say,
poetry or to select stories in
which that sentiment exists.
But, we did that, but in
addition to that, we experimented
with an abstract depiction
of the nine moods.
And, that was the work
we took to India.
So, it was with, to Indian music.
We commissioned that work also
where it was an Indian composer.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, with facial,
I mean, there's a lot of gesture.
>> Anuradha Nehru: A lot of gesture.
>> Catherine Kerst: And, hand
mudras, and also facial --
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes.
>> Catherine Kerst: Expressions.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: You worked with.
>> Anuradha Nehru: We have
an entire language of gesture
that forms our vocabulary of
movement for us to tell our stories,
and that's supplemented
with facial expressions.
Facial expressions is a key
part of storytelling for us.
We use the combination of
the language of gesture
as well as facial expressions.
But, in this work called "Rasa",
we did that, but we extended it to,
so for say, let's take
sadness, Karunyam.
We used a story to depict sadness,
and then we continued the work
by using just movement of
the body to express sadness.
And, because I, as I said earlier,
I do believe even just the movement
of the body, the vocabulary
of the actual entire body
movement itself is very expressive.
Besides having, in
addition to that language
of gesture and facial expressions.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, is there a
difference in performing in Indian
with an Indian audience who has some
concept of the heritage of Kuchipudi
as opposed to an audience here?
And, how is that as --
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes.
>> Catherine Kerst: As a
performer and a choreographer?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
Yeah. It's a very good question.
I mean, for years, I've
struggled with this.
It's always easier to dance in India
because there's so much context,
and the audience just gets it.
They, having, you know, been
brought up in the same culture.
Performing in America
has been very challenging
because there's so much that's lost.
People don't understand the language
of the poetry, of the lyrics.
They don't understand,
necessarily, the music itself.
They don't understand
the language of gestures.
So, it's a lot was lost, and so
we tried to supplement our dance
with extensive narratives
or narration, you know,
just explaining each dance before
dancing it which helped somewhat.
>> Catherine Kerst: Sure.
To some extent, and now, more
recently because we've experimented
with surtitles, I think
that's even more,
brings Indian dance even closer.
But, I also do believe that we
could bring Indian dance closer
to our audiences just, you
know, without necessarily having
to explain it extensively.
But, we've got to get there in terms
of how we choreograph Indian dance.
And, there are ways to just enjoy
it without necessarily having
to spell it out, and I
think it'll get there.
>> Catherine Kerst: I
could imagine, you know,
I could imagine surtitles could
help, but they could also, in a way,
come in the way of just responding.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah, so it--
>> Catherine Kerst: To the artistry.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah,
so that is a struggle.
That is a struggle, and I
think surtitles should not be,
should be used minimally
and not too extensively.
Just to give context as
opposed to if it's overused,
then the audience will be
reading rather than watching.
And so, there has to be a fine
balance, and that's all part
of the learning process, I think.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's fascinating.
Could you speak a little
bit about the jewelry
and the makeup and the costume?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: For performance.
It's a very distinctive costume.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes, and
that's largely because of
where Indian dance originated.
It was a temple dance form,
and so it's pretty elaborate.
But, the costuming and the
ornamentation is quite elaborate,
has always been where the
dancer was seen as a devadasi
or the dancer was dancing for
the gods and so was dressed
in this fashion for that purpose.
But, and we've, to a large extent,
continued that tradition
of dressing.
Although, in many more contemporary
Indian dance works today,
you see a lot of simplification
to the ornamentation.
And, I think it adds, it
adds to the dance form
in certain contexts,
but it's not critical.
I do believe it's not critical.
I do believe we ourselves,
even at Kalanidhi have,
when we've presented dances
which have more secular themes
which are more social
themes, we've moved away
from the very elaborate
costuming and ornamentation
because it just doesn't go.
It does go with the more traditional
dancing, but not necessarily
with the more social context,
contextual dances that we present.
>> Catherine Kerst: Do you have any
young men who are studying with you?
>> Anuradha Nehru: This has
been another big challenge.
I've had several boys start
learning dance and one
or two became excellent, but
it's just tragic that all
of my boy students give
up in middle school.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: The social
pressures are enormous,
and it's tragic that
they all give up.
So, it, no, I'm an all-female
dance company as of today.
Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
So, in India, are there students?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes.
>> Catherine Kerst: Are
there male students?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes, there are.
But, still in the minority, but
there are several male students,
and they're beautiful to watch.
I brought two male dancers for
my production last weekend,
one from India and one from
another part of the United States.
It just adds-- because
there's a certain energy
that male dancers bring
to Indian dance
that female dancers don't and can't.
>> Catherine Kerst: Or together.
>> Anuradha Nehru:
And, together, yeah.
We dance together,
and it just adds a lot
to the energy and to the dance.
But, no, I haven't been successful.
>> Catherine Kerst: No.
I can imagine that it would
be very, very difficult.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: Has the dance
form changed as it becomes more
of a woman's tradition, or?
I just wonder because--
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: It
seems like a huge change,
did you say, in 75 years.
>> Anuradha Nehru: In 75 years, yes.
I think it has changed.
It's, there is definitely more
of the softer, graceful movements
that you see more of a predominance
of the more graceful movements
in our repertoire today.
Although we haven't
given up on the vibrancy.
I mean, that's the
beauty of Kuchipudi.
>> Catherine Kerst: Oh, no.
>> Anuradha Nehru: It has,
it has very vibrant, dynamic,
strong movement vocabulary, but at
the same time, it has this very,
very graceful, soft
movement as well.
And, it is the confluence
of these two
that make Kuchipudi
special, I think.
And, and I think, just because it's
female practitioners, we, perhaps,
it looks slightly different today
than it would have 75 years ago
with an all-male dance form.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, the
main gurus in India now,
are they still male, or
are they also female?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah,
there's still a lot
of male Kuchipudi gurus,
interestingly.
We do have female teachers as
well, but still, in the village
of Kuchipudi, for example,
today, we have mostly male gurus.
>> Catherine Kerst: Really?
I see.
>> Anuradha Nehru:
Mostly, they're all male.
Not to say that there aren't female
teachers elsewhere in the country,
elsewhere in the country.
In the cities, we have a
lot of female gurus, but,
still in the heartland of
Kuchipudi, it's all male dominated.
>> Catherine Kerst: Interesting.
So, it was originally male
dominated where they performed as,
they performed in women's roles.
Now, it's reversed, in a sense.
>> Anuradha Nehru: It is.
>> Catherine Kerst: In your
school and in other contexts.
>> Anuradha Nehru: It is.
>> Catherine Kerst: Where they're,
the young women are portraying.
>> Anuradha Nehru:
Portraying male characters.
It's taken a full circle.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: I understand
that there are different strains
of Kuchipudi that are
currently taught.
With Vempati how would
you characterize his,
his distinctive expression
of Kuchipudi dance?
>> Anuradha Nehru: I think
when Vempati Chinna Satyam has
definitely moved away from the style
that he had learned in
the village of Kuchipudi.
>> Catherine Kerst: Really?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
He was hugely influenced by the
dance scene in Madras those days.
He had moved to Chennai
in the '50s, 1950s,
and Bharatanatyam there was a huge
revival of Bharatanatyam in Madras.
So, I keep interchanging Madras
and Chennai because in the '50s,
Madras, it was known as Madras.
It's today known as Chennai, but and
so, there was a lot of excitement
with the revival of
Bharatanatyam in Madras.
And so, he got to see a lot of
Bharatanatyam there in Madras
and was influenced,
definitely, by it.
And, I think that definitely changed
his sense of aesthetics and he also,
by introducing women
to the dance form,
also the dance form did
change a little bit.
And, he spent a lot of time
in removing certain aspects
of the dance drama form that he
felt was not being received as well
in Madras those days and
evolved the solo form in a way
that was more appealing to
the audiences in Madras.
And so, yes, Vempati
Chinna Satyam's style
of Kuchipudi is distinctly different
from the other guru's styles
that you see even today,
both in India and abroad.
And, it's very recognizable
difference to the dance,
Indian classical dance aficionados.
But, to a non --
>> Catherine Kerst: How
would you describe it?
>> Anuradha Nehru: So, it's, I
mean, without, it's much easier
to describe it with a demonstration,
but in words, I think, for example,
he took away the whole
spoken, the dialogues.
So, part of Kuchipudi tradition
was to have the spoken word
as part of the production.
Dancers would not only
come and sing on stage,
but they would speak on stage.
>> Catherine Kerst: Oh.
>> Anuradha Nehru: So, it
was, it was very theatrical.
So, there would be a lot
of drama as well as dance.
They would, they would speak
as well as go and dance.
So, they would do both,
and Vempati's significant
intervention was
to remove the spoken
word almost completely.
He would, even if there
was the spoken word as part
of the production, it
would be sung by a singer.
It would not be recited or
sung or spoken by the dancer.
So, that was definitely
a big change, and he,
some would say he refined
the movements.
Others would argue against it.
It depends on who you're talking to.
And, I think his primary
contribution, also,
has been to create
solo work which a lot
of the other gurus
had not, have not.
They've taken parts of the
dance drama, drama works,
and they've presented as solos,
but they have not independently
choreographed solos.
>> Catherine Kerst: I see.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
I'm talking about in
his time, not today.
So, that was a huge difference
where a lot of his body
of work had new solo dancers
created by him to poetry
that extended beyond
the poems and the songs
that were used traditionally
in the Kuchipudi village.
And, he was the first
Kuchipudi guru that also,
that also choreographed an entire
dance drama that had a social theme
to it and not a religious
theme to it.
He addressed the whole caste
system, based his production
on Rabindranath Tagore's work.
>> Catherine Kerst: Really?
>> Anuradha Nehru: And, so he
had this incredible courage.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: To, and he,
singularly, I think, was responsible
for bringing Kuchipudi
out of the village, A,
and made it popular
around the world.
He was immensely popular
in his time.
He took his productions
around the world.
>> Catherine Kerst: I see.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
Europe, America, Australia,
everywhere.
Yeah, he was singularly responsible
for popularizing Kuchipudi,
I would say, in his time.
>> Catherine Kerst: Because
I was under the impression
that for a while Kuchipudi
had to, had to really show
that it was a classical
art form and not.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Exactly.
>> Catherine Kerst: A folk
form, which it certainly is not.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Exactly.
Yeah, and I think, I think Vempati
Chinna Satyam contributed enormously
to that legacy and to fight
for its place amongst the
classical dances in India.
Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: Remarkable.
>> Anuradha Nehru: But, you know,
the spoken word is not, it's still,
I think, a strong component
of Kuchipudi today, and we,
not only Kuchipudi artists are
finding ways to incorporate it
into their productions, but other
forms have adopted that as well now.
We see Bharatanatyam and other
dance forms using the spoken word
and incorporating that
as an element.
And, I don't see why not because
it is in the Natya Shastra.
The Natya Shastra speaks
about the four different kinds
of expressions being vachika which
is spoken being ornamentation
or costuming, being sattvika which
is more expression of the soul
and expression through gesture.
So, they've outlined four different
forms of expression, and so really,
it's open to any classical Indian
dance form to use these elements
as part of their productions
or performance.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, is that
Telugu for your students, or?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Not necessarily.
>> Catherine Kerst: Are many
of them Telugu speakers?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes, I
have a lot of Telugu speakers,
but I also have a lot
of non-Telugu speakers.
>> Catherine Kerst: I would imagine.
>> Anuradha Nehru:
Amongst my students.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, the
spoken word would be English, or?
>> Anuradha Nehru:
Today it's English.
Today, it's English because
that is the unifying language.
>> Catherine Kerst:
Of course, yeah, yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And, it
doesn't, yeah, and I think it's fine
because it's, it's
language that is used,
it's a spoken word that's used.
Which language that spoken word
is in is almost irrelevant.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: As long
as it helps to communicate.
>> Catherine Kerst: Exactly.
>> Anuradha Nehru: To our audiences.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
So, you mentioned how Vempati
sort of pushed the boundaries
in terms of social issues.
In a sense, you've also followed
in his footsteps in that.
Could you talk a little
bit about that?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Sure.
I'm sure it has impacted
itself on me.
I, in fact, one of my,
one of his most favorite,
one of my most favorite
productions from all
of his productions is Chandalika,
which is the one with
the social theme.
I just, because I connected to it
so deeply, and I always believed
that the dance form
has enough depth to it
that it can communicate any concept,
not necessarily just
religious concepts.
And so, yes, part of, part
of my personal objective
and Kalanidhi's objective is to
push the boundaries of the art form
and to be able to make Kuchipudi
more accessible to a wider
and more diverse audience and
bring it closer to the people
that we present, present
Kuchipudi to.
Yes, and that I think
that's probably why,
from the very early stages of
when the company was formed,
we were constantly looking
for ways to experiment
with not only different forms
of music, but even concepts.
We did a few, a couple of
pieces on women's rights.
We took music.
Again, the music for that
was very much Indian.
It was an Indian album that was
created around women's rights
by a social, by a nonprofit
organization
in India called Breakthrough, and
it was just, it touched me so deeply
that we wanted to experiment
choreographing to that music.
And so, I think, ultimately,
we need to use the art form
to express what we feel and what
we connect to in our hearts.
So, and this art form, this dance
style, offers that vocabulary to us
to express whatever it is we want
to express and to push boundaries
and to bring it closer
to our audience.
>> Catherine Kerst: Well, I can.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Am
I repeating myself?
>> Catherine Kerst: Well, I
can imagine for your young,
the young women that this is
very validating and very, very,
very important in our culture today.
Now, almost more than ever,
just seeking validity as women
and what our role is and our, and
so, thisis, yeah, so admirable.
>> Anuradha Nehru:
Absolutely, and I think,
I think partly why Kalanidhi dance
is able to draw its dancers back
to it, they want to come back to
it because they see that we are,
they find it relevant
to their lives.
They are able to, themselves,
experiment with the things
that they connect to
using Kuchipudi.
In fact, one of my dancers has
collaborated with a hip-hop artist
and she presented a project
called the Nayika Project,
and it was an amazing collaboration
where two completely different
art forms, hip hop and Kuchipudi,
came together to explore the Nayika.
The Nayika Project was about the
different types of women, you know.
There are different types of
women that has been described
in great detail in
the Natya Shastra.
You know, the daring woman, the
woman who is devious or, you know,
there are different
categories of women
that were elaborated
in the Natya Shastra.
So, Chitra, my, one of my company
dancers, took this and, this concept
and collaborated with
a hip-hop artist.
This is great, so I just feel
that the next, it's endless.
The potential and possibilities
are endless, and that is why it's
so exciting for Kalanidhi dancers
that here we are at Kalanidhi trying
to provide a platform for them
to take off and to experiment
and to find meaning
through Kuchipudi.
>> Catherine Kerst: And,
to make it their own.
Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And to make it
their own, to make it relevant.
>> Catherine Kerst:
And meaningful, yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And, that is the
only way, I think, for this art form
to survive and flourish
in this new home.
>> Catherine Kerst:
Very exciting, yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: That it's found.
Yeah, that was a very tough time.
We went through two tough
periods in its history.
[laughs] And, one was, yeah,
in '98, '98 to 2002 was
when my husband got a transfer to
Indonesia, and I left for that,
for the sake of the family.
And, at that time we were
just still very much a school,
and it was still very
tough, very hard to leave.
And, when I came back in 2002, I
did not have any idea what I wanted
to do because I was little older
now in 2002, and I wasn't sure
if I was ready to start with
six year olds all over again.
And, but my senior dancers came back
and said, "You don't have a choice.
We're waiting for you to restart,
and we need to come back to dance."
And so, I restarted in 2002,
and I mean, Kalanidhi --
Kuchipudi Kalanidhi was a nonprofit
organization that was incorporated
in '91, and so that
was not closed down.
Meaning, we were, we
became inactive,
but I just picked it
up and restarted.
Yeah. In 2003, I restarted.
And, 2005 was when the company
was formed with my senior dancers.
>> Catherine Kerst: And,
what year did you first come
to the Washington area?
>> Anuradha Nehru: I
first came in '86, yeah.
So, I was informally teaching
once a week at an Indian school,
India School it was called, once
a week from '87 onwards, actually.
But, I incorporated
Kalanidhi in '91.
>> Catherine Kerst: '91.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Thea Austen (off camera): What
are your plans for the future now
that you've gotten your
25 year celebration?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah, so yeah.
We have used the 25th year
celebrations to kind of introspect
as to what next for Kalanidhi, in
a sense, and because we, today,
have a group of very passionate
dancers that are part of Kalanidhi,
it's become our objective to
try and make it self-sustaining,
to in a way that would allow them
to continue to practice Kuchipudi
and continue to teach it to the
successive generations of dancers.
So, we have a very
clear goal in mind.
It's a very ambitious goal, to, we
don't know if we, we definitely want
to start on its path of creating a
center for Kalanidhi where Indian,
where Kuchipudi can be taught
and new work can be
created and presented.
We plan to start on
that process now,
and we'll see where we get with it.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's ambitious.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Very ambitious.
>> Catherine Kerst: I mean, it's
a wonderful goal, but I'm thinking
of the atmosphere in the
arts community sometimes
that is not always supported as
well as it really should be, and--
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: And that's, so
it's a huge struggle and a challenge
to do, to continue with
even excellent art.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Right.
It is. It is a huge challenge.
We completely recognize
how big a challenge it is,
but we have to have a dream.
>> Catherine Kerst: Of course.
Of course.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And, if
we don't have the dream,
we can't even begin working
towards attaining the dream.
And, we have a passion that,
and that passion is
fueling that dream, and.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's excellent.
>> Anuradha Nehru: What the future
holds for us, we don't know,
but we certainly are going
to put our energy and passion
into working towards that dream.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's the way to do it.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: So, now
that the 25th is passed,
what are your next
projects or performances?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah, well, we,
my board is now, finally, you know,
coming back to the nitty
gritty as we, you know,
we recognize that we're a very small
dance company and we need to begin
with have a business plan.
We need to have and expanded and
more diverse board of directors
and so we're working on very
practical things like that.
More immediately, we've
got a business plan
that we just put together, and
in fact, I've got a meeting
in two days that's talking about
how do we expand the board.
And, the board's trying to
help me to get to a stage
where I can start affording to
pay at least three to four dancers
so they're full-time with me.
>> Catherine Kerst: Excellent, yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And so, even
if we have a small core group,
at least we have a core group that
can, that we can sustain, and then,
we can then do so much more
with creating new work.
Because being such a small dance
company, I and the one or two others
that are helping me do everything,
we do all the administrative work,
all the marketing work, the
fundraising work, the logistics,
the organization, the
teaching, and the creating.
So, it limits us enormously,
and so even having three,
four people would immediately
free our time up to do more.
And, those are our immediate steps.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's wonderful.
Thinking as an archivist, are you
preserving old video and recordings
and so on of performances and?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst:
Because it's so valuable.
>> Anuradha Nehru: I know.
>> Catherine Kerst: And, it's a
huge, that's also a huge challenge
because the media needs
to be digitized.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Digitized.
>> Catherine Kerst:
And preserved and then.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
So, unfortunately, you know, we
do have a lot of video footage
of early performances in
the old VHS cassettes.
Very poor quality, and I
have digitized them recently,
in the last year, into
the DVD format, and.
But, a lot of the resolution
is lost even in that process.
I was told that was not
what I should have done.
What I should have done is put it
on a wav format, but in any event,
we've tried to save some
of the early video footage,
but more recently, we're
doing better in terms
of archiving our more recent work.
>> Catherine Kerst:
It's very valuable.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: Very important.
I'm aware of that.
I know.
>> Catherine Kerst: But,
it is also quite difficult.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah,
because it's all costs again.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah, yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: And,
it needs to be maintained.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And maintained.
>> Catherine Kerst: Exactly.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah,
so our hope is also to,
to expand our programming
in the coming years.
So far, we've been able to
just do one show a year,
one big show a year, and we perform
a lot in the rest of the year.
But, mostly very small performances,
and we take part in local festivals
and community based
organized events.
We do get invited to participate
in other festivals in other cities.
Sometimes in New York, like
the Erasing Borders Festival.
So, we do those kinds
of performances,
but Kalanidhi initiated programs
have typically been once a year.
So, the board wants us to at least
expand that to two times a year
to begin with because the minute it
is Kalanidhi initiated performance,
it requires a huge amount of
investment in terms of money.
And, so that's another step
towards expanding programming that's
in our control.
>> Catherine Kerst: Do the
young dancers also perform?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes, a lot.
I mean, the young dancers.
>> Catherine Kerst: You want
to get them on the stage.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Perform the most.
>> Catherine Kerst: Wonderful.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Because every
single community opportunity they
get, they perform.
So, we send them out because that's
how they become good dancers.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yes.
Right.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And, yeah.
So, we have a huge emphasis.
One of my dancers has now, who's
part of the staff, is now the,
looks after the school
aspect of things.
So, her main job is to
get those little kids
out to every community based
performance opportunity possible.
>> Catherine Kerst: Excellent.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And so, they
are just becoming experienced
in performance.
And so, when they're
join the company,
they're already pretty
comfortable on stage.
>> Catherine Kerst:
That's wonderful.
I mean.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: And, even
if they don't become dancers,
that experience is invaluable.
>> Anuradha Nehru: It's invaluable.
>> Catherine Kerst:
Really, the confidence.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Exactly.
It helps them in so many ways, and
I mean, the testimonials we have
from students, parents,
returning students, alumni,
are really amazing what
dance does for them,
how deeply meaningful an experience.
This whole 25th anniversary
performance was an incredible
experience because so many
of our alumni came back
from different parts of the
country to be a part of it,
and they've been flying back every
weekend in the month of October.
>> Catherine Kerst: Really?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Just so they
could do the group rehearsals
in order to perform, and it was a
very sentimental, nostalgic feeling
after the show because they all were
in tears saying, "Thank you so much
for including us, for
thinking of inviting us.
It's just reminding us all over
again how special it is to be
with other fellow dancers
and dance on stage."
And so, it's heartwarming
at many levels.
Yeah.
>> Catherine Kerst: Wonderful.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah, it.
Yeah. Is there something
that you'd like to cover
that I hadn't asked about?
>> Thea Austen: Or teachers, or
poetry, or work with [inaudible].
Or, you've done some
interesting work
with different composers [inaudible]
and had pieces commissioned.
Do you do a lot of that?
What do you tell a
composer when you're asking
for something to be
composed for you?
You choreograph after
the piece is composed?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes, yes.
>> So, what do you?
>> Anuradha Nehru: After it's
composed but before it's recorded.
So, typically, what happens
is it starts with a concept.
It starts with a concept,
and sometimes,
the concept requires lyrics,
so then poetry is written
to which revolves around
that concept.
And, then, and then, I think at
that's the stage where I roughly,
I have a rough sketch of how
I visualize each of the scenes
or each of those concepts.
And so, I write out the notes
for each of those concepts,
and that is what I take
to the music composer.
And, if there are lyrics,
I give him the lyrics.
And, if it's just a
concept, an abstract concept,
I give him the notes
around that concept.
And, he creates the music, and
it's usually just the raw score,
and the raw score is
like a piano track.
It's, if it's a flutist, if the
music composer is a flutist,
then he would create the
raw score on a flute.
And, this last, last composer
was a singer, so he just sang.
His voice was the raw score,
and based off of that raw score,
we choreograph the whole work.
And then, I videotape that
work and I take it with me
for the final recording
because the final recording has
to be exactly fitting
the choreography.
And so, it's quite
a tedious process.
It's quite an expensive process.
So, it's not easy to do new
work every, very often because,
first of all, it takes
a lot of time.
Secondly, it's very
expensive to do it.
And, it's much easier
to take music off
of the net and choreograph to it.
And, that's possible for
individual pieces, but when you want
to put a whole thematic
work together,
this is the best way to do it.
And, that's why when, when
collaborators like Ryan Brown come,
it's such a luxury for us because
we don't have to worry about,
it's like handed to us, the music
and the background notes,
the concept is handed.
And then, it's just a question
of choreographing to the music.
Yeah. And, Ryan has approached
us for yet another collaboration
which we're exploring
and to present in 2018,
and this is the first time
it's going to be a work
which has no opera singers.
So, it's going to be his
orchestra playing to our dancers.
So, I'm really excited about it.
Yeah. So, this is like having an
entire western orchestra playing
for Kuchipudi dancers.
It's an amazing opportunity.
>> Catherine Kerst: Which genre
are they, is he going towards?
>> Anuradha Nehru: He's going
to send me the detailed notes.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Next week.
He was waiting for my November
6th show to be finished.
It's called "The Enchanted Forest".
Are you familiar with it?
I have to, I have to read about
it and learn more about it.
I know very little right now.
It's a short work.
It's like a 30 minute work, but
it's just the idea is exciting.
But, I must, I'd like to
say that I owe a huge, huge,
huge debt to my guru, my teacher
Guru Vempati Chinna Satyam
for giving so generously his
knowledge and for being a role model
for the passion that
he had for the art form
and the way he spent his
time where dance and music
and the art superseded
everything else for him.
So, it was, it's, to walk in
his footsteps is truly an honor
for students of his, and
I'm always ever grateful
for being one of his students.
And, I think, I consider myself
lucky to have been his student,
and I don't think I
would have been able
to do what I've done
without his guidance.
>> Thea Austen: I love the
combination of your passion
for the tradition and your
passion for innovation
at the same time it sounds like
it's both, both are his legacies.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yes.
>> Thea Austen: And, I loved,
I mean, when you were talking
about the Rameau project
with Ryan, I just loved,
among the other things,
the minuets that were done
with both the baroque figures and
Kuchipudi figures at the same time
and how they beautifully
they work together.
>> Catherine Kerst: I know.
Amazing.
>> Anuradha Nehru: And, that's
where I credit Ryan Brown
to even have a vision where he saw
these three incredibly different
dance forms coming together.
I mean, and to be able to
take that step to invite three
such diverse groups together and
to have them work with each other.
Just to take that step itself
requires a man with a vision
and so we were all, you know,
didn't know what to make of it,
but we were excited
by the opportunity.
>> Thea Austen: You know,
it's interesting to me
that [inaudible] have absolute
commitment to your art form
and to the idea of
trying [inaudible]
because sometimes will love an
art form but feel like they have
to change it in order to make
it acceptable to somebody else.
But, the feeling that I
get from both of you is
that not only is it a complete
commitment to the art forms
that you have, but they will stand
on their own and are strong enough
to come forward and integrate
with other kinds of art forms
that people will come to them,
you know, come to the art.
You don't have to.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Yeah.
You've articulated
it so beautifully.
That's.
>> Catherine Kerst: I think.
>> Anuradha Nehru: So true.
That's absolutely true.
It is, and that is the real
crux of, I think, what we do,
you know, and what we believe in.
And, that is the real
challenge also.
How do you stay true to the art
form because it is so beautiful,
it has so much depth
and complexity and
yet make it relevant
to your audience?
And, that's where the innovation
has to come into play to be able
to bring it to your audience.
>> Thea Austen: You did a great job.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Thank you.
>> Catherine Kerst: Yeah.
Wonderful.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Thank you.
>> Thea Austen: Is there anything
else you would like to talk about?
>> Anuradha Nehru: Wow.
You know, maybe I could speak
to what dance means to me.
You know, ultimately, I do feel,
because I'm an Indian classical
dance practitioner, for me,
dance is very, it's very much
part of the spiritual journey
that I am going through as
an individual as I live life.
And, I feel the practice
evolves as I mature, the dance,
the dance evolves with me,
the, and I feel that all of us
in our lives are searching for
something that's greater than us,
that's bigger than ourselves.
And, to me, dance provides that.
Dance provides that
vehicle to search
for something that's
bigger than oneself.
It could be a goal.
It could be the search for
beauty, search for the truth,
search for happiness, search for
love, and I am eternally grateful
that I've been given this
vehicle which is Kuchipudi
and Indian classical
dance that helps me evolve
as a person using the art form.
And, for that, I'm
eternally grateful.
>> Catherine Kerst: Well,
Anuradha, this has been delightful
and very meaningful to talk
to you about your dancers,
about your dance, your concept
of the dance, the history.
Fascinating, and it
all, it's an amazing,
it's an amazing life you've
lived and continue to live
with the innovation
of bringing tradition,
making it accessible
to new audiences.
Very exciting.
So, thank you so much.
>> Anuradha Nehru: No, thank you.
>> Catherine Kerst:
Really appreciate.
Really enjoyed talking to you.
>> Anuradha Nehru: Thank you so
much for giving me this opportunity
to talk about Kuchipudi and to
bring it to a larger audience.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.